Hello world it Saroj and
how are you supposed to find
a meaningful job or career
in your life?
I'm going to talk about eight steps you
can take today that will help you do
just that.
Thanks to social media.
You can get attention and validation for
your life choices by sharing pieces of
yourself online. We live in an
age of instant gratification.
Many times we do things just for
the likes they'll receive. In fact,
there are entire exhibits that have
been built just for Instagram selfies
because of this,
the expectations of how awesome our lives,
our from our friends and
family can run pretty high.
So while it might be easy to say,
I love my new job at Airbnb,
it's a lot harder to say I don't
know what I want to do with my life.
Because of how people could
negatively perceived that.
It can be really hard to admit that
your last, if you let yourself,
your mind could just wander through all
the negative things people could think
of you like,
doesn't he have a plan or why isn't she
contributing something useful instead of
waiting around?
But the fact is this,
it is completely okay to be confused,
to be uncertain about what
you want to do in life.
In the preindustrial period,
there were about 30 different trades a
person could do from being a blacksmith
to a barrel maker,
but fast forward to today and career
websites list tens of thousands of
potential jobs you could do and the result
of all of these options or that often
we get so anxious about making the wrong
choice that we end up not making any
choice at all. Psychologists
call this the paradox of choice.
Too many options can leave you standing
in one place like a deer caught in the
headlights and because
we can be so risk averse,
our minds tend to exaggerate everything
that could possibly go wrong.
So it's not easy to change jobs
or find an entirely new job.
There's bound to be a lot of confusion
you go through in order to get there and
that's okay. You've got to
recognize this confusion as natural,
get comfortable with it and once you do
that, you'll be able to move forward.
Accepting your confusion is the first
step, but clearing it up is the next.
In order to clear it up, you've got to
take some time to reflect on yourself.
Who are you? What are your unique
gifts? What matters to you the most?
What kind of impact do you
want to have in the world?
Take some time to be introspective.
I keep a journal where I write about
a paragraph summary of my day at least
twice a week.
A helpful exercise can be to write down
five traits that best describe you and
then ask to close friends to give you five
traits they would use to describe you.
You might be surprised by what they say
and you'll definitely learn more about
yourself. Think about what you
can't stop yourself from doing.
What are your habits?
What are your flaws?
You've got a unique set of skills that
you likely don't even fully realize and
it's when you are able to combine all
those skills in a way that no one else
can, that you'll find success. Discover
your weirdness and embrace it fully.
The more you know yourself,
the more capable you will be.
A finding work that matters to you.
And let's face it, nobody's perfect.
Everybody's got some kind of imperfection.
And that's okay because everybody has
something unique to contribute to the
world. So it's important to
remember to love yourself,
and that's a daily practice.
If you love yourself and all
your beautiful imperfections,
you'll take better care of your health.
You'll have more confidence, more style,
more swag, and you'll be more courageous
to do what you've always wanted to do.
It gives you the freedom to fail,
to learn from that failure and
the drive to continue despite it.
So writing out your personal strengths
and weaknesses is a great way to learn
more about yourself. But picking a
career you've never tried before,
based on that alone is a mistake.
You could find that the job that perfectly
fits the profile you've created for
yourself is in reality,
not that fulfilling or exciting to you.
So instead of planning,
then implementing act first and reflect
later by switching to a model of rapid
experimentation. Find some
free time, whether that's in
the evenings and weekends.
If you currently have a day job
or if you have some savings,
even better use this time to try out a
list of things that you've always wanted
to try to think.
You might enjoy.
Developing security techniques
for the Internet of things.
Volunteer for an open source
project that centers around that.
How about product management?
Sales content creation.
There are online communities and projects
that will allow you to take on any
role you'd like. Give each of them a
shot. Try One out for as long as you like.
Trying not speculating is the only way
to really know whether or not you'd enjoy
the activity.
I worked as a software engineer for a
few years before randomly deciding to try
out a role as a developer
educator at Twillio.
That's where I realized that I preferred
teaching code to maintaining it and
while I worked there,
one of my many side projects was starting
a youtube channel and I had to start
doing it to realize that,
hey,
this is what I actually enjoy
more than anything else. In fact,
I would take a huge pay cut just to be
able to do this full time and that's
exactly what I did.
Unimportant realization for me was that
it's not about finding what you love to
do, it's about finding the
people you love to serve.
If you can find that almost any work
you do for them immediately becomes
fulfilling. And for me it's
been the developer community.
Imagine you could literally do anything
and have any kind of life you'd want.
What does that life look like?
In order to get to that life
you need to create a goal plan.
What I do is I have a set
of daily, weekly, monthly,
and five year goals
that I write to myself.
I make sure that the smaller goals are
achievable in the short term and that
gives me a positive feedback loop.
A set of mini victories that
encourage me to continue.
Goals are your dreams there. What gets
you excited to wake up in the morning?
They're the driving force in your life.
That can be anything you'd like and
meaningful work is one big way to help you
achieve them. It's important to be
really specific about your goals.
If they're too broad,
like teach people instead of teach
children programming in python,
you'll never get started and
once you have your goals,
you have to learn to say no to
everything else, but that goal,
just imagine if you had
the idea to start Google,
Amazon and Facebook 20 years ago.
If you picked one of them,
you can be worth billions
of dollars right now,
but if you try it out all three at once,
you'd be nowhere.
Everyone has great ideas,
but the problem is that too many
great ideas cancel each other out.
The most successful people in history,
everyone from Einstein to Jay z had mono
maniacal focus on a larger single goal.
If you feel like a goal is too boring
to dedicate all your time to it than aim
higher,
the more ambitious the goal,
the more exciting it becomes and the key
to be able to have this laser focus is
self discipline.
Developing real discipline is one of
the most overlooked but most important
things you can do for yourself
professionally and for your own happiness.
One of the questions I get the
most is how did you get so smart?
It's not that I'm some genius who came
out of the womb knowing AI like the back
of my hand.
I developed the discipline to study it
and so did every other great practitioner
in this field.
Discipline is the difference between
those who fail and those who succeed.
It's a learned skill and you can build
it just like you build any other skill
one step at a time. So start small. Get
yourself to say, meditate every day.
Then add onto it maybe a journal entry
every night or brushing your teeth twice
a day instead of once or not letting
yourself work from home or getting up at a
certain time every day. The more you
make these habits a part of your routine,
the more second nature they'll become to
you and thus the more discipline you'll
build. And this discipline carries
out into every aspect of your life.
When I was first starting my
youtube channel, it was really,
really hard to release two videos a week.
And as my audience grew,
so did the expectations they had,
I was under a lot of pressure
and it was very uncomfortable.
But because I had the discipline
to stick to my release schedule,
everything became easier
and more manageable.
Over time I learned to adapt and now
it all feels like second nature to do.
Over time,
my work has definitely improved and I
can credit that improvement in a huge way
to one thing,
being open to feedback.
I am constantly reading comments,
replies,
emails from my viewers and using
it all to improve my content.
Sometimes it can sting,
but it's really important to let go of
your ego when it comes to constructive
feedback and use it to help you
guide your work. If you can do that,
you'll not only be able
to find meaningful work,
but you'll be able to excel at it
like no one ever did before you.
So I hope these tips were helpful and
the best time to get started on your
journey to find meaningful work is
right now. So what are you waiting for?
The world is your playground. Please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now, I've got to go serve the
people I love. So thanks for watching.